не відпускає знали Я не розумію що
робити за цими дверима
чому я вас слухаю так
в школі ви заблокували
Доброго дня Це засідання Верховної Ради
України і ми пам'ятаємо що 31 рік
діяльності нашого парламенту завжди була
пряма трансляція а-а сесійних засідань
51-ї статті регламенту
я
проходьте без відеокамери будь ласка 5
це не містить взагалі жодної значить
народним депутатом забороняється вносити
до засідань та використовувати під час
проведення пленарного засідання плакати
лозунги учні мовці інші предмети які не
мають на меті забезпечені законодавчої
діяльності
дуже важливі закони зокрема закон про
медіа зокрема заяву про наших
військовополонених Оленівка але вже
котре засідання поспіль керівництво
Верховної Ради блокує висвітлення
діяльності Верховної Ради України а
канал Рада який цього року отримали
п'ять разів більше а грошей на свою
діяльність і Майже 500 млн грн сьогодні
отримає висвітлює що завгодно тільки не
діяльність засідання Верховної Ради
України
такі Лещенко і з камерою знімав все що
тут відбувається з трибуни це було ок
не можу я не пам'ятаю коли на зорі
роботи Парла
менту було прямої там можливості таких
трансляцій приноситься всюди камеру
знімав цю засідання і показував роботу
Верховної Ради України і власне зараз Ми
принесли камеру для того щоб записати
засідання Верховної Ради України і в
запису транслювати дискусія які тут
відбуваються
через парламент який має захищати
Україну проходить просувати якісь свої
хотелки зараз щойно ухвалили закон який
по суті дозволяє руському міру повертати
повертатися в Україну так званий закон
про медіа А що трапилось
взяло випускників
сказали не допускаємо відеокамери тому
що це потрібно бути на підставі 51-ї
статті
будь ласка я тільки що під мені
показують 51 статтю регламенту яка
забороняє гучномовці і яка не
забороняється поки наші воїни на фронті
охороняють країну от Вона ця державна
охорона зараз насправді охороняє не
парламентаризм не демократія не
свободуть слова а забороняє депутатам
пронести ну звичайнісіньку камеру
дивіться так роботи народних депутатів
створено канал Рада що телеканали рада
давно показує собаку патрона котика
мурзіка кого завгодно полковника ще одне
питання підстави мене народного депутата
не випускали щойно з зали оця особа
купиловський заблокував двері і не давав
їм це було вилучився і пояснив причину
своїх дій ми поза політикою виконуємо
свої функціональні обов'язки ви зараз не
поза політикою ви будуєте диктатуру що
таке диктатура диктатура - це коли
всупереч закону забороняють людям
виборцям знати як працюють їхні обранці
тут депута говорить справа показати
своїм виборцям дискусія яка сьогодні
відбувалася в якій в 10 тому б/у уявили
таку картинку та навіть природу
есть есть это опустили хлопці нижче
плінтуса так само з держави це насправді
те що держава от ви своїм роками
принижуючи депутата без причини різниці
держави
нам зараз забороняють пронести камеру
тут для того щоб ми могли знімати
засідання парламенту потім його в запису
показувати от охорона нам зараз це
забороняє скажіть таке було Хоч раз
колись в історії колоски
слова які на думку Міністерства
економіки
керівництво парламенту чергове
відмовилися ставити в порядок денний а
Постанову Якою має висвітлюватися ця
діяльність для того щоб кожен українець
знав чим займається Верховна Рада
очевидно зрозуміло Чому влада так
боїться цієї публічності тому що
сьогодні через бюджет протягнуто ганебну
норму коли гроші так званого дорожнього
фонду які мали йти на армію знову
передалися на краківництво доріг І за це
проголосували 245 народних депутатів
241 народний депутат слуги народу і
майже в повному складі А шлютки опзж які
сьогодні є кращими друзями слух народу
Ну а ще разом вони проголосували закон
про медіа яким русифікують українські
медіапростірна рада працює максимально
непрозорому режимі і не хоче щоб
телеканал Рада зокрема який веде запис
трансляції але потім не показує цей
запис в цій грі і це порушує всі можливі
демократичні норми е-е і віддаляє нас
від європейських норм парламентаризму Ми
сьогодні тоді принесли камеру свою за Ну
як згадав за те що колись я як
телевізійник і журналіст і оператор і
вантажер зараз ось е-е камера яка
потребує те що відбувається у Верховній
Раді абсолютно всі виступи тому
і це ганьба яку сьогодні намагаються
провести через Верховну Раду буде
захистом і показана без цензура і без
купюрки наша камера Дуже заважає
сьогодні ховати які кінці в воду те що
тут відбувається голосувати всі ці
закони які не мають нічого спільного з
патріотизмом нічого спільного з воєнним
станом нічого спільного із захистом
України замість того щоб зараз
утримувати ситуацію на ринку Павлова
навпаки намагаються запровадити Актив
який призведе лише до дефіциту пального
і поновлення черг на заправках тобто
така собі Зелена економіка ми будемо
показувати що тут відбувається бо всі
закони і по постанови які приймаються в
інтересах суспільства ми
європейська Солідарність голосуємо за
цей Сьогодні ми прийняли після того як
європейська Солідарність дуже активно
втрутилася і вимагала все ж таки
Постанову із зверненням до світової
спільноти по подіям по вбивству
російського у українських
військовополонівці сьогодні Верховна
Рада прийняла 316 голосів і е голосувала
і монобільшості це дуже позитивний
варіант але коли після після того
фактично
вбивають бюджет на догоду великому
крадівництву і забирає ці гроші у
військових ми таке сприйняти не можемо і
мовчати ми не будемо І те що відбувалося
сьогодні це є абсолютно абсурдом про те
все ж таки здоровий глузд